I believe that you should be putting out  somewhere between 5 and 15 posts on  social media a day  across three to four different platforms  and to the reaction I appreciate that  the reason I always get Jesus is because  most of you know you're posting once a  day if you're a superstar once a week if  you're like in it and once a month if  you're normal and never if you're kind  of 50 of this crowd for most human  beings on Earth of the 8 billion doing  the kind of exercise that is required  whether physically or mentally and  having the eating regimen that is  required to actually be in shape is  [ __ ] Jesus they don't want to do it  so a lot of people in here are just  Hypocrites because you really sell it  and live it in physical but you don't  live it in marketing and business